I know everyone wants to hear my
thoughts on the suspension I never knew
you could be suspended for a flagrant
too that happened seven years ago
um
and I also didn't know you get suspended
for interacting with a crowd that's
flipping you double Birds
and and and and yelling your name and
chance that you suck and like you
interact with them I didn't know that
either uh saying that
my guys play well my guys played really
well stepped up to the challenge
and it was absolutely incredible to see
I hope everyone enjoyed the game the way
I I mean I can't say I really enjoyed
the game quite frankly my fellas was in
the dog fight or it's in a dog fight and
just not being able to participate in
that dog fight that's crushing like that
like because you just feel like you know
you're leaving them out there by
themselves leaving them astray to just
figure it out so to not participate in
that dog fight
that's what bothers me the most and so
I'm very thankful uh of the effort that
guys put out there yesterday
um to save our season